okay hi everyone
welcome to another episode of science
and technology q
a for kids and others i see we have a
bunch of questions
uh saved up here so let's see where
should we go first
okay we have a question from william uh
why does occam's razor work
okay first question is what is occam's
razor
so it's a kind of principle about
theories in science
and it was due to a chap called william
of ockham back
nearly a thousand years ago now i think
and when people are trying to explain
things
in science or maybe elsewhere it's a
question of how elaborate
is the explanation supposed to be is it
what is more likely an explanation
that's very elaborate or a simple
explanation let's say for example
that i'm
looking at the
screen that i'm looking at right now and
the question is
why does it have or no let me pick
another example let's say
i observe
that uh a tree
is has a branch that's fallen off it
okay and i have a variety of
explanations one of my explanations
is there was a beaver and the beaver
climbed up the tree
and the beaver sawed its way through
this branch meaning to use it for a
beaver dam
but then when the branch fell down the
beaver ran away and all i can see is
that was branched on the ground
or another possible explanation is there
was a
strong wind and the wind broke the
branch and the branch fell on the ground
and there might be a whole bunch of
other explanations and the question is
which explanation is the most likely to
be right
is it the very elaborate explanation or
is it
the simpler explanation it's kind of
like
when you wonder why did something happen
in the world
was it a giant conspiracy that involved
all these different moving parts
or was it just oh somebody made a
mistake and so that's why it happened
so arkham's razer uh
it's often stated in terms of don't
don't sort of introduce
extra ideas when you don't need them to
explain
what's going on in something and in
science
it's been a very common principle that's
applied and sometimes it works
and sometimes it doesn't so for instance
in um let's say in biology
there's the question of sort of
why are there why is there some feature
of some animal
and there's the elaborate explanation
that has many many steps
and there's the simple oh it it just
grew that way because of some simple
thing
you know what's likely to be the right
explanation
and this is a it's a very interesting
question
whether there is a principal reason why
occam's razor should work
sometimes in areas like technology
or in human built things there's sort of
a reason why it should work
let's say uh because in a sense
something has been made progressively
more streamlined
it's like like um there used to be some
very elaborate procedure for doing
something
and it was obviously more efficient to
make the procedure simpler
so eventually the thing became simple
and
so it was eventually it sort of became
streamlined but
became sort of the simplest explanation
works
but it this sort of also relates to
questions like
if you have a theory that is very
elegant
and it just says you put these few
things in and you get all this stuff out
is that a more likely to be correct
theory than a theory where
there's a lot of very complicated things
that go in to get some particular thing
out
different fields that different
intuitions that tend to work for example
in medicine
it's often the case that things are just
very very complicated
in explaining what's going on in
medicine
sometimes i i am uh i think it's sort of
the
that the even when you think you
understand what's going on there's even
some other effect and some other thing
that's complicated
that that can be important now
the the the experience in physics
has tended to be that the simplest
theory is most likely to be right
um it's uh sometimes doesn't quite work
that way for example in the standard
model of particle physics
there's some sort of external pieces
that are kind of weird
and the world wouldn't be the way it is
so far as we know apart from those extra
pieces but they're
like why do these exist why are they
these extra pieces
for example famous example so people
know about electrons
there are two other types of particles
that are very similar to electrons
things called muons things called tau
leptons
nobody knows why those things exist
they're just things that
happen to exist in physics and they're
sort of
not physics you might think could have
been simpler if those didn't exist
now hopefully before too long we'll
understand why those exist and why it's
inevitable
that from a perhaps very simple
underlying structure of physics
those have to exist but as of right now
it just looks like those are extra
little twiddles that don't really need
to exist to
uh to make physics work but
i think um i mean the question of of
when do simpler explanations when a
simpler explanation is the right thing
is
is is there's another issue that comes
up with those
um let's say that you have some data
let's say you plot it on a graph there's
a bunch of points
and you say what is the model
that describes these points well
one thing you can do is say oh let's
just put a straight line through these
points doesn't go exactly through the
points but it's more or less
aligned with the points okay there's our
model another possibility
is you can have not a straight line but
some very wiggly line that exactly goes
through every single point
and you say which is the better model
the thing with very few
very small number of parameters the very
the model is very easy to state you
could sort of say it in a sentence it's
just like the
the this thing is proportional to 2.7
times that thing
it's a straight line or the thing that
requires a big long explanation about
how oh it's this complicated
mathematical function it wiggles up and
down
but it gets every single data point
which is the better model
so that turns out to be a not
such a simple question it's sort of a
trade-off you can be
fit the data more accurately or you can
have a simpler model
how do you trade off those two things in
a sense you need some sort of measure
of how complicated is your model and
then you need some criterion
to say how you trade off complexity of
model for
uh for how well it fits the specific
data you have
and so particularly in modern machine
learning there are a bunch of somewhat
streamlined
criteria that are used to decide this
question of have you over
fit the data have you had a model that
yes it fits the data really well
but it's a goofy model because it's an
incredibly over complicated model
or not and and sometimes also
there's a question of what does it even
mean to have a good model is it a model
that
um um uh that has
some um
[Music]
what what is the model that you're
making
something that is supposed to be a real
representation of the mechanism
that underlies how the thing works or is
it merely something that
explains what's going to happen and just
gives you a criterion for explaining
what's going to happen
so for example there are
particularly with modern machine
learning you can say here are a bunch of
examples of what happens
okay give me a black box that will tell
me how another example is going to work
out
you've got something that does can do a
pretty good job of that but if you say
well
what is the mechanism by which this
thing happens
well that may be extremely difficult to
know
it may just seem like there's a thing it
fits the data
it gives me an answer that fits the data
but we don't know the mechanism
and then the other possibility is oh
you've got some model where you can look
inside and see the mechanism
and it's sort of interesting in
different fields people
sort of expect different levels of sort
of mechanistic explanation
i think well for example in medicine
there are a bunch of
famous formulas that are widely used in
medicine
that if you try to say what's their
mechanism it's like it's completely
crazy it doesn't make any sense
but yet as empirical formulas they work
quite well famous one is the
body surface area formula which is often
used for various kinds of drug dosing
and um
it's uh it says you know the amount of
of a drug you should give people
should be proportional to this quantity
that is sort of the surface area of
their
you know of of of their bodies as
opposed to the volume
um but the formula for surface area is
something completely crazy
whose units don't even match i mean it
depends on height and various other
things
um and uh but yet it is empirically used
and and
quite successful for lots of purposes
so this this question sort of what's
inside the model and is there a
mechanistic
thing that's going on versus is it just
a model where you plug numbers in
and it works is an interesting question
and in this kind of back to the original
sort of occam's razor question
the question of uh if you have these
different theories
you might have a trade-off between a
theory
that fits the data you have really well
um but it's a very very complicated
theory
versus a theory where the theory is
simple but doesn't fit the data quite so
well
i think at the time of william of ockham
he was really
sort of arguing against just incredibly
bizarre
to us today sort of pre-scientific
theories of how things worked
um and arguing for something where there
were simpler mechanistic explanations of
things
and as i say sometimes simple works
there are other times where it doesn't
work so well um and
uh uh it's it is a it's a it's a curious
thing to know
when simplicity is rewarded so for
instance
there are cases i mentioned in
technology there are also cases in
places like biology
where an incredibly elaborate way to
make something
is probably going to have more ways to
fail and probably isn't going to be the
way the thing gets made
um it probably that probably the the
sort of the process of making things
will sort of
gradually uh sort of squash out the
inefficiencies
you know if you say uh how does a
particular form in biology get made
um the explanation oh it folds in this
way and then it twists in this way
and then does that and then does this
and then does that and so on and there's
a step
25 steps that's less likely to be
correct
than something that involves fewer steps
but just in the sort of confusion of
biology
there are plenty of things that work in
surprisingly complicated ways
um that do involve a surprising number
of steps
to to achieve to to get to the point
that that we actually observe
let's see and questions here
oh boy um
that's a question from a tori asking me
uh do i know how to cook i'm afraid
that's one of the
domains of human knowledge in which i am
deeply deficient
uh no i am i'm absolutely pathetic in
that in that domain
um it's uh uh
somehow there's a certain um
intuition about sort of creating uh
things that i suppose is
sort of chemical synthesis uh creating
food
all those kinds of things but um uh i've
not
been a personal not personally partaken
in those things in any
in any appropriate way i think the thing
that's always
surprising at a sort of meta scientific
level about food
is isn't it remarkable that you can just
eat all this random stuff
and it somehow can turn into growing
pieces of
you even though you are
you know made of things that seem very
different
from the things you eat in a sense
that's that's one of the sort of
universal features of life
uh on earth at least is the fact that
it's all made from these components like
proteins
and proteins are made from this limited
number of amino acids you know every
protein
is just a chain of of some sequence of
these
about 20 different possible amino acids
and when we eat food we're getting all
the food we're eating
plant food uh animal food etc is all
contains proteins a little bit different
between plants and animals
um that's why people who who choose to
not eat
any kind of meat have to supplement
their diets with with things that have
some of those extra amino acids which
just aren't made by plants
but nevertheless it's um
it's something where it's sort of
remarkable that there's enough
universality
in the kinds of things that uh that we
eat
that it's possible to sort of eat almost
anything and
end up being able to use that to make
pieces of yourself so to speak
it's also sort of remarkable that if you
look at not just
amino acids and proteins but also
just random things like you know
magnesium or potassium or whatever else
that sort of there's enough kind of
mixing
of stuff that and there's a small enough
number of different chemical elements
that are important to life
that we sort of seem to manage to get
kind of enough of all of these things
um in a uh from just random stuff that
we eat we don't have to say
oh i'm going to very carefully eat this
or that thing because i'm
specifically trying to you know i don't
i don't have to eat
bone in order to make bones so to speak
i can sort of eat
almost anything that is part of this
kind of collection of
kind of life made and life-making
uh kinds of things and and that sort of
works
now i mean there's there's also the
question of well okay
you can get away with eating all these
different things uh you know what do you
like to eat so to speak and that gets
one into the whole
elaborate complicated theory of how
things like taste and so on work
and uh and the great importance that the
sort of physical
uh characteristics of food have on how
they taste i mean it's always remarkable
to me
that you know a thing that you know you
slice something up
and it will taste different than if you
just you know bite into it so to speak
um it really matters what the sort of
physical surface of food is
to how it's how you perceive it and
that's not totally surprising because
the way that you're perceiving the taste
of food is that
you know the food on your tongue is
actually
physically interacting with the taste
buds that are on your tongue
so if you you know if you slice that
banana up the
the sliced surface of the banana may
have a different
essentially chemical interaction with
the taste buds on your tongue
than the than the sort of whole mashed
up banana mashed up with your teeth so
to speak
so i mean there are it's it's it's sort
of interesting to see
in this there's still a uh not far from
complete understanding of sort of
gastronomy at the
at the molecular level so to speak and
and at what sort of
what kinds of things you might combine
and it's also interesting when you
when you see you know at some fancy
restaurant you'll see some
some bizarre unusual combination of this
with that
and it's like how do you know that's
going to work um
and uh there isn't uh i think yet
a a good kind of uh physics style
theory of sort of how you combine
different kinds of things
in um in the gastronomical universe so
to speak
uh to be able to make things that um uh
that work i mean
and sometimes things i i don't know i
think a very american thing is you know
peanut butter and jelly or something
which is something i don't think i've
i've ever had it actually and it sounds
horrible to me but but it's something
where gosh it actually works
and um uh um the uh
i think um these are things where
sort of interesting how those
combinations can be made
um in any case the the uh the but the
the answer to the original question is
no i'm
i'm i'm pathetically ignorant of of
cooking things um
the uh so let's see it's a question here
how from amrit how would you explain it
the goal of your physics project
uh to a five-year-old hmm
five's a little young five's a little
young
i think one would start off by saying
you pick up a thing an object
what's it made of if you were to
have if you were to look at smaller and
smaller and smaller scale
what's this thing made of and you might
say
well turns out this thing is made of
little
things called atoms and they're very
small
and then you say well what's what's
everything else made of like what's
if if we just have empty space and of
course that's not a thing that
that one that one people intrinsically
understand you know
there's air but the idea of vacuum where
there's the
fact that something in the air is is is
its own separate concept and the fact
that
there's a vacuum where there's sort of
nothing there is
is as yet a yet a separate concept
but it's kind of the um uh the
the thing of of what um uh
how does how does um uh
what what is the universe sort of
fundamentally made of
um is is something that um
um one uh one's going for there
i'm not sure i think five is a little
young to explain that with with
serious clarity i think that um
um you might also say
uh well okay here's another approach if
you know about video games
which your average modern five-year-old
is going to know something about
um the question is could you make a
video game
that is just like the whole world that's
just got everything that we know about
in the world
in the video game could somebody program
a video game to just be like the world
and and do we know how to do that do we
know
how to make a thing that
will be just like the world and is
what's underneath it something that
uh you know you could run on your phone
or your computer or whatever else
i mean i think that's another another
possible way into it and then
to be able to ask well if we could do
that
can we figure out kind of what moves are
possible
in the actual universe by doing that
just like somebody programmed that video
game
that you're using and the you know the
character you have in the video game can
make various moves
but the person who programmed it kind of
decided those moves to make
um and the question is if we were able
to sort of
make a program for the universe could we
then figure out
what all things are possible in in the
universe
you know i have to say that that this
whole question
of kind of what is the world made out of
is is a question that has been of sort
of philosophical interest
for well throughout the sort of history
of recorded philosophy
i'm not sure how often it's been of
deeply practical
uh sort of central interest i think it's
more one of those kinds of things that
it's sort of the ultimate foundation for
understanding how you build up science
but it's not obvious that it's kind of
the the everyday here and now
question that people need to ask just as
when you study biology or medicine
uh yes it's nice to know something about
the origin of life and the fundamental
things that make life life versus
non-life
but it's not the everyday question that
you have to ask in doing biology or
medicine or something like that
so
oh there's a question here about um
from frederick about um
pandemics and crises and so on and that
perhaps the next one will be an attack
on the internet
what do you think look i think one of
the things that um
uh is
always a question for uh
us our species is you know what are the
existential threats to our species
what you know if we look at the fossil
record of life on earth
goes back close to three billion years
we can see that there were species that
lasted for a while
sometimes they were really successful
they lasted for hundreds of millions of
years
and then they weren't extinct and sort
of the question of
is that a necessary feature of how
biology works
that species come up uh things things
are figured out for a while dinosaurs do
really well for a while
trilobites do really well for a while
and then
you know all good things come to an end
so to speak and then
uh the the the fossil record shows that
species dies out
is that something that's somehow
inevitable or is it
the case that oh uh something goofy
happened
an asteroid hit the earth whatever
that's why the dinosaurs died out
it didn't really need to happen that way
so to speak
i don't think we really know the answer
to that but i think it's an interesting
question what uh sort of what sort of
existential threats which which might
like you know make our species go
extinct might exist i mean there are
certainly things that um uh you know
could happen that are really bad
the things that we kind of know from
science aren't going to happen the sun
is not going to explode as a supernova
it doesn't happen to stars the size of
the sun
could there be a supernova nearby yeah
they could be would cause trouble for us
is it likely it's extremely unlikely
um it's uh you know in in by nearby i
mean
in a star within 10 light years 20 light
years something like that
um i think there are i'm not sure at
what point there are stars that
that could have a supernova explosion
exactly what effects it would have on
earth i don't think completely known
um but you know it's an example
something can happen uh you know could a
giant asteroid crash into the earth yeah
it could happen
has happened a few times in the last few
billion years but isn't very common
um could there be you know when i was a
kid
the the most obvious existential threat
was
you know people start using all those
nuclear weapons they've accumulated
and uh then the question is what happens
if you detonate
a thousand nuclear explosions um on the
earth
what happens to the earth and uh a
popular idea was this idea of so-called
nuclear winter
so the popular idea was and it's kind of
an echo of of uh sort of climate change
kinds of questions
but um the observation the idea was
uh the earth you know is the temperature
it is because it gets
uh heat from the sun and so on gets
radiation
solar radiation and all that kind of
thing but if you detonate a bunch of
nuclear explosions
and on the earth you throw up a bunch of
dust
and the dust ends up in the upper
atmosphere and the dust ends up blocking
sunlight
for at least a few years and uh the
world ends up being very cold
and that that happened presumably when
the uh at the at the cretaceous tertiary
boundary 65 million years ago
um when that uh asteroid hit the earth
um that uh caused trouble for the
dinosaurs
um one of the things that happened is it
was probably pretty cold for a couple of
years
as this dust got thrown into the upper
atmosphere
and the same thing happened for example
when krakatoa
uh volcano in indonesia exploded in the
late 1800s um was a dramatic explosion
it threw dust into the upper atmosphere
and it cooled the surface of the earth
down by a certain amount
um obviously in in today's world despite
uh you know it would be it would be uh
we'd
all be a bit frustrated if the earth was
was cold and dark for a couple of years
but in most places um it wouldn't uh
wipe out the species
i mean the the dinosaurs probably uh we
assumed didn't know how to make fires
and things like that
um i i don't know if we know for
absolutely certain that dinosaurs
couldn't make fire but presumably they
couldn't
um the uh and so you know that wasn't
an option so to speak to keep warm
during that period of time
but you know if you ask what other
things what other really bad things
could happen i mean it always pandemic
has always been on the list of
of things that could happen and there's
sort of a a features of pandemics as you
sort of change
the dial of what was actually going on
like for example
you can have a virus that is incredibly
fatal to people and you know you catch
the virus and it
it it with high probability kills you
but
but the thing about a virus like that is
it's hard for that virus to get
transmitted
because viruses get transmitted by
somebody has the virus
and then they are sort of breathing out
the virus or whatever else
and and they're walking around with the
virus and then they can give it to other
people the virus has a host
that allows it to kind of jump to the
next person and so on if the virus
has killed the person then they're not
out and about and spreading
the virus to other people so for viruses
there's a sort of complicated
natural selection process that
will make things not be
uh it tends to not be good for spreading
of a virus
to have it be uh too fatal to its host
sort of the best thing for probably for
virus is you know
it doesn't really do the virus any good
to have the host be uh
off on their own so to speak you know
off in bed for
for a week it's better for the virus to
have very little effect on the host
so the host is out and about spreading
the virus i mean one sees similar
strategies
in lots of kinds of plants that need to
spread their seeds
and they want animals to spread their
seeds and they want the animals to be
out and about
and and doing that and the last thing
they want is to
you know hurt the animal and have it not
be able to walk around and spread the
seeds
so but um uh
you know there are there are other
potential uh sort of things that
um there are plenty of things that can
go wrong and uh the question of sort of
things going wrong with the internet is
an interesting one
and um the uh um
you know there are so to explain a
little bit about
uh viruses and worms and in general
malware on the internet
let's talk a little bit about that so
the um the basic
well let's see the very first worm
i remember when that was created and and
know some of the people involved
um the the first internet worm
it's here's here's what it did it did a
very weird thing
it was a piece of a program running on a
computer
and its goal was much much like a living
organism
to get copies of itself made on lots and
lots of other computers
and so it was doing the sort of
self-reproduction thing that we expect
living systems to do
but it was doing it on a computer so it
was a program running on a computer
and the program would basically use the
internet
to uh it would it would be it would
contact other computers
or other computers would contact a
particular computer
and they would that
that program would get transferred
through the internet to that other
computer and then it will start running
on the other computer
and then it would start trying to make
copies of itself be running on yet more
computers
and after if it starts off on one
computer and then it goes to five
computers and then each of those five
computers
spreads it to five more computers pretty
soon you spread through an awful lot of
computers
at least to computers that are connected
to the internet
and it it uh
typically well it's always a complicated
thing because when you
are trying to you go to a website
and the website says there are just
amazing cool things you can do
just download this piece of software and
it will do amazing cool things for you
so the concern is that it could be the
case that that piece of software is
absolutely
uh just going to do those amazing cool
things and that's all it's going to do
could also be that you download that
piece of software and it's actually
going to do bad things as well
for example it's going to do that thing
that that early worm did
and say yeah great i'm now running in
your computer let me see if i can get
other people to download me
and then i'll be able to make copies of
myself and be able to run on lots of
other computers as well
and that that's why for example one of
the things that's
important in in the modern world is that
things that get that where you say
there's this piece of software and
you're you're being told download this
piece of software and run it
it's important that the the thing that
that software is is signed somehow
it has some kind of digital signature
that says yes
this came from the place you thought it
came from
and you can decide are you going to
trust this particular company or
whatever
but the first thing is to confirm that
the thing you got actually came from the
thing you thought it came from
and there's a whole mechanism of sort of
how you make these trust networks
to decide yes the thing i got has this
digital signature
how do i trust that digital signature i
have to have some kind of certificate
authority
that is the thing that tells me that i
should trust this digital signature
and that it really came from that place
but the
the there are there are always ways that
things get um uh the things like that
get avoided and
places and bugs and operating systems
and so on
that allow uh pieces of software that
are essentially self-reproducing
software
to be spread from computer to computer
and that's the most common scenario
for uh for one to get
kind of a a large-scale spreading
of um uh of of of of
malware of bad software so to speak
it's a complicated thing because in
modern warfare
it's pretty important to have um
the uh uh to be able to sort of attack
the computers of your enemy
and there have been a number of times in
in sort of uh
fairly recent history where things like
that
have been done i mean the famous
examples in um
uh estonia then in georgia um
where well those were the estonia case
was a
was a slightly different one that was
one where oh it sort of argued whether
that was a
russian government thing or whether it
was a the russian government just
asked people to go visit the estonian
government websites
all at the same time and that caused
those web
sites to get overloaded and to go down
um but then
you know there are other cases where
it's like okay you're going to
go attack somewhere and um
the you know if if you want to do that
it's kind of
a modern version of uh you know if
you're going to wage a war
you know do you have control of the
skies do you have control of
of this or that uh uh thing and having
sort of control of cyberspace
is is something that's going to be it's
already important and it's going to be
even more important
um and there are cases where uh
where that's that's been done and the
way that it tends to work
is there's well
how do you build these pieces of malware
mostly you need to find bugs and
operating systems or bugs and programs
and application programs that will allow
you
to somehow use those bugs to take over
computers
and i mean one thing worth understanding
is
why should it be the case that for
example
you could take something like a a random
webcam on a door
or something and be able to take it take
it over
why should it be built so that it's
possible to take it over
you know doesn't that seem like a goofy
thing to do why isn't it just being
a uh you know a an electronic doorbell
and nothing else why isn't it just being
a
a
a network router and nothing else
the reason that it tends to be something
else is sort of the fundamental reason
that software
works so well to begin with which is
these things tend to be
set up to be universal computers they
they tend to be set up to be things that
yes you thought it was just a router but
in fact
the router needs to be able to use some
sophisticated algorithm to decide
whether it should send traffic here or
there and in order to do that
by far the most efficient way to do that
is to have it be
operating on a universal computer that
could be programmed to do anything
so it can be programmed to run this
particular sophisticated adaptive
algorithm
or it could be programmed to do
something else or whatever else so it
tends to be the case that sort of
in almost all programs end up being
essentially like universal computers
within that program
you can program anything and it tends to
be that way just because that's the way
you get programs to be
to be smart and sophisticated and to
have
lots of potential capabilities but that
feature
is also the weakness of of sort of lots
and lots
of the software infrastructure of the
world because it means that
these these systems in principle have
the capability to do anything
and so if you can only kind of worm your
way into that capability
you can make them do anything including
bad
things that they really weren't intended
to do so a big part of kind of
sort of the breaking into computer
systems consists of finding some way
you go from stepping stone to stepping
stone and find some way
to get to the point where you can make
you can program the system to do
anything
once you can program the system to do
anything you're in
and you can you can set it up to do
whatever uh sort of
bad things you you wanted to do and so
on but so
the way it tends to work is there's sort
of a
uh people trying to find those kinds of
vulnerabilities those kinds of places
where you can
sort of get your way into computer
systems
and there's a a sort of a strange world
of people um uh doing that type of thing
the the sort of the most valuable thing
to have is what gets called a zero-day
exploit
which means i found a problem i found a
bug in such and such an operating system
i found a way
to sort of do this or that weird thing
and to break into that operating system
i found this way to do it
and i know it but nobody else does and
so on day
zero if if people start using it
nobody knows that vulnerability nobody
knows how to patch the operating system
how to get around it it's like a thing
that is a fresh possibility that there
won't be a counter measure for
so sort of the most valuable thing is a
zero-day exploit that nobody has
discovered before
and and so there's a whole strange arms
trade
of uh of people uh creating and selling
zero-day exploits
and there's sort of a you know
governments hoarding these kinds of
things
and waiting for the moment when they can
potentially be used to attack an
adversary
so that's uh that's the kind of thing
that that can happen now
you know there have been uh some
definite high
nuisance value um kinds of uh
attacks on the internet there hasn't
been a case where
sort of the whole internet has been
brought down um
by um by this the very first
one was the uh the morris were maybe
1991 maybe
1990 something like that the very first
of these
um of these of these things had a pretty
big effect on the internet
it was pretty much most computer systems
most companies
um the thing had sort of reproduced
itself into their computers
and it kept on reproducing reproducing
reproducing
and it had meant that the most of the
computer time that was being spent
was just running the code of this worm
and not doing whatever the computers
were supposed to do
i have to say i felt very pleased with
myself at the time because
our company was not affected by that
worm uh for a strange reason
which was not completely unanticipated
um
when one connected one's company were
connected to the internet
there was a gateway computer that one
used and
one of the things that that i decided
for our company was
uh because i kind of was somewhat aware
of these computer security issues
it was like let's use the weirdest
computer we have
to be the gateway computer and we used
some
strange japanese workstation that was
commercially not
successful at all but we had
ported our software to that computer so
we had we had one of these computers
and we used that as a gateway computer
why was that a good thing
it was a good thing because the way the
worm had to work it had to be set up to
have a version
that ran on each kind of computer that
it would visit it's kind of like
if you were a virus like a biological
virus
uh they're sort of if you wanted to be a
multi-species virus like i can affect
humans i can affect
you know wild turkeys i can affect cats
i can affect dogs
you probably need variants of the virus
to infect
each of those different species and so
similarly with computer viruses
you needed to take the underlying code
of the virus
or the worm and and recompile it
uh just rebuild the code for each
different kind of computer
and nobody had bothered to build the
people who created this this worm
hadn't created a version for this
totally weird computer
so it couldn't affect us and uh and so
we were not we were not affected by that
but the question of could the whole
internet be kind of taken down
by some uh sort of uh
kind of um computer virus malware type
thing
probably the answer is yes um the
internet is set up to be quite resilient
to those kinds of things it was
it was built originally as as kind of a
a
sort of military-inspired project and it
was built with the intention
of having a lot of redundancy so so that
there are many connections from one
place to another
many different routes that packets can
take to go from one place to another
and even if you uh sort of say
everything in city x is taken out
it's still the case that data can get by
going through city y
can get to its destination so it's it's
intended to be very
resilient like that however uh there are
still
is plenty of places where the internet
is using
uh software systems that um
route traffic route internet data from
one place to another and so on and i'm
quite certain that there's a way
that it's conceivable that um some
piece of sort of bad software could
spread through all of those places that
are routing traffic
to the internet and take the whole thing
down now people try to
avoid certain systems being taken down
that the typical term for this is air
gapping
a system which means basically there's a
place where
you just can't get data to a particular
system
there's an air gap there's just there's
no wire that connects
the system to the other now you say
there's no wire well of course there's
wireless
transmission of things and so you have
to worry about that
and in the most secure kinds of computer
installations
people do things like put computers
inside
uh copper boxes where you can you can
use that copper box to stop
any kind of radio signal from getting in
and that's kind of or getting out for
that matter
and that's kind of the the most secure
way to do things
but of course it's rather inconvenient
to have your computer
inside a copper box and it's also quite
inconvenient and increasingly so in the
modern world
to have your computer disconnected from
the internet so
there's a and there's a great tendency
to connect
just because oh it might be convenient
to do that to connect
all imaginable computers will imagine
computer like
things to the internet because well why
not so to speak
well of course that has the effect that
um
uh if somebody is trying to attack the
computer there is a path to get into the
computer
i mean for example i remember an exploit
done by somebody i i knew actually
um that was uh
something where it's like can you get
this was at a government
lab where there were sort of secret
computers and there were non-secret
computers
could you get to the secret computers
from the non-secret computers
how would you do that well he noticed
that there was a printer
that could be accessed in days when
printers were expensive things
there was a printer that could be
accessed both from the secure
secret computers and from the non-secure
non-secret computers
and so the question was well the printer
is supposed to be something where
you just print to it nothing comes back
from the printer
but oh well this printer was just a
little bit too clever
so in fact there were things that when a
when for example
when the printer got jammed the printer
would send a message back saying
i'm a jammed printer and it would send
it back to a computer
and so it wasn't the case that it was
while you might have thought oh it's
just a one-way transmission of
information
it wasn't and so it was possible by by
sort of little
sort of clever steps to send data in
from the non-secure side into the
printer the printer oh it's just
supposed to be a printer but actually
it was sending data back out and it sent
data back
out to the secure side and then that
data caused a computer there to send
data back in
and so pretty soon it had established a
communication channel
through this printer which is something
you're not supposed to you might not
think you were able to communicate
through
but that's a typical example of how it's
like well
why not give it these capabilities and
then the question of how do you
guarantee
that those capabilities can't allow the
wrong things to happen
that's a very challenging thing people
people sometimes imagine
that you will be able to make like a
mathematical theorem that says nothing
bad could possibly happen
with this particular piece of software
the problem with that is
that the the way these things work if
you can prove a mathematical theorem
like that
it pretty much tells you that your
software can't
do sophisticated things as soon as the
software is capable of doing
sophisticated things
it becomes impossible to sort of prove
slam dunk complete mathematical theorem
type results
about what the software does and so
that's sort of an another challenging
uh sort of trade-off is you can either
have the software do sophisticated
things
or you can have it be very secure and be
sure that you know what it's doing
that it's not doing anything bad i mean
it's it's a little bit similar to the
trade-off that happens a lot
with how complicated do you want your
whole password mechanism to be
you know do you want to use some uh
two-factor authentication where the
thing is
texting you a message on your phone and
doing this and doing that
oh well i don't want to do that it's
just too much of a nuisance
um well you know that's a that's a
trade-off it's more secure if you do
those things it's more difficult for
somebody to
just uh you know steal your password and
break into your account
on the other hand every single time you
log in it's going to take you longer
because you have to go through all these
different steps so that's a sort of a
simple version of that
of the general trade-off but um yeah so
i think
in terms of these sort of what would
happen
if is it possible for the whole internet
to be taken down
my guess is the answer is yes um is it
obvious how to do it
not really i mean there are things that
could happen
that are very very bizarre like for
example one thing that could happen
is uh which people worry about is um
what has been seen mostly in the past
is software typed attacks on computers
you
you send a piece of bad software into a
computer it starts running on the
computer
it does things it wasn't supposed to do
now sometimes those
effects those sort of uh bad software
effects can have an effect
in the real physical world so a very
famous example of this
historical example was the um attack on
the
iranian uh um
uranium uh iranian
uh uranium uh
centrifuges that were uh
being used to separate uranium-235 from
uranium-238
and they involve spinning very rapidly
this
uranium gas and the
this attack that was done on them
attacked the control software that was
responsible for spinning all these
centrifuges
and um it caused the control software to
make them spin very very fast much
faster than they should have been
spinning and eventually to self-destruct
and um so that was something which was
achieved by essentially a pure software
attack
it was just changing the control system
to
not work the way it was supposed to work
and
to give indications that said oh yeah
i'm working just fine when in fact it
wasn't
um that was a military attack um
uh in sort of a cyber space military
attack
um and i think the um uh but that's a
case where it sort of crossed over
from being an attack in in in
software to being a physical attack now
you know people worry about the same
kinds of things
for planes and cars and medical devices
and so on
can you uh can you basically from so
pure
software get out of the physical world
but another direction
is from something more like the physical
world can you get to the software world
and so one of the issues is when you
have a microprocessor
or some other kind of chip that might
exist let's say in the routing
uh systems of the internet um is it the
case
that in the in the billion transistors
that are on that chip
they're all doing different things and
they're all setting up all of the
the the sort of the the uh the computing
capabilities of that microprocessor
are they all doing what you think
they're doing and or are there
is there essentially a hardware virus
that somewhere in all those billion
transistors
there are things that are like if if
only the particular right collection of
bits
is seen in this particular register the
suddenly the thing will
make itself switch off or or do
something crazy
and nobody really knows it's a hard
thing to determine
because it's one of these things where
you say there's a billion transistors
here
what could they possibly do it's like
saying there's a
this program and it's millions of lines
long what could it possibly do
but it's something where um again it's
it's sort of a potential crossover
from the kind of um the pure the
hardware world
to the software world and nobody knows
whether you know some
uh some uh sort of
terrible thing has been done where lots
of the
you know the routing uh systems of of
the world of the internet
have some hardware virus in them where
if just exactly the right sequence of
you know hundreds of bits is sent into
all these routers suddenly they all
uh you know they all overheat and and uh
blow up in puffs of green smoke or
or do something else um it's it's
something very hard to
to determine um and uh hopefully that
hasn't been done but but
one it's hard to know but so that's an
example of a type of thing that could
happen now
now the other thing that could happen
another question is
you know one thing is that was
intentionally done for some military
purpose
or otherwise another possibility is
somehow this happened by mistake
um you know could there be the bug that
takes down the internet by mistake
um or could there be even something
where
one imagined that one was making this ai
system
that was going to somehow make the world
a better place
but actually the ai system ended up uh
causing everything to to fail in some
very ugly way
certainly that could happen i mean we
already can see one little sideshow of
that
um in uh in the internet in general
which is uh lots of systems lots of uh
places where you know the news feeds of
social media and so on
um uh are you know effectively
that what you see in your news feed is
being selected by an ai
what you see in search results is sort
of being selected by an ai and
those ais are originally given certain
motivations
like you know increase the ad revenue
based on you know the results and what's
coming up and
what kinds of ads can be shown and who's
going to look at these ads and all those
kinds of things and
but in the end that that ranking is
is pretty much picked by an ai in a
first approximation
there are sort of human tweaks for
better or worse i think often worse
that are made to those rankings but um
but fundamentally it's it's some kind of
ai that's picking those things and an ai
that was originally programmed for some
particular purpose now
you know what if the ai does the wrong
thing
what if the best way to get people to
look at those news feeds is to have
incredibly shocking news that appeals to
one set of people and horrifies another
set of people
and what if you do that across different
groups of people
and have the results that those groups
of people all think completely different
things about what's going on in the
world because they saw completely
different news feeds
well you know to some extent that's
happening and that's kind of a sign of
of sort of the unintentional
consequences of the ai doing what it was
underlying supposed to do and so that
that's a thing where
where one can kind of um uh see
sort of the unintentional uh consequence
of that i mean i'll tell
uh with respect to the internet there
are things that could happen
for example the all the sort of
cleverness
of knowing oh you route messages on the
internet in this particular
uh sequence of machines in order to make
them arrive faster
things could go horribly wrong with that
in the early days of the internet when
it was still the arpa net
things did go wrong with that i remember
a time when um
there was a question of you know where
should this data be routed through so it
goes through this computer this computer
this computer
and in those days the the protocol for
the internet
had computers sort of reporting how much
time did it take
to go through this particular relay
computer and there was a particular
computer in hawaii
that for some reason something had gone
wrong with it and it kept on reporting
it took a negative amount of time to go
through me
so that meant if you said well what's
the total time it was going to take to
get a message from here to there
it's like well if you send it through
hawaii it will take less time because it
takes a negative time to go through the
computer in hawaii
so needless to say lots and lots of
messages got routed through this
computer in hawaii
and the computer in hawaii completely
overloaded
and um but and and so the internet kind
of slowed to a crawl
as a result of of that kind of error in
the routing messages could that happen
again
well it's still the case that the actual
technology that's used to figure out
routing messages is a little bit hokey
and a little bit weird
um but you know there's probably enough
diversity and
that particular kind of thing couldn't
really happen um
but you know could something along those
lines potentially happen maybe
people talked about for a while it's not
a popular thing anymore
they talked about internet storms and
the idea was
kind of like the the weather you know
things are happening in the
in the sort of the flow of messages
around the internet it's kind of like
the flow of air
and circulation in the earth's
atmosphere and it's like funny things
could happen
there could be an internet storm that
would cause you know this particular set
of machines to get very busy and
and things to you know it's like a
hurricane on the internet
uh people don't talk about that much
these days um i think that really didn't
happen
as much as people thought it might um
and i think uh
uh but but you know those are those are
those are some possibilities
let's see um
okay this tarka is saying the first
virus apparently was a creeper system as
an experimental self-replicating virus
971
okay i didn't know that um
the
let's see
oh boy so many questions here
it's a question um i just
do a few more here sorry i've i've i've
spent a long time describing these um
recent answers let's see
[Music]
um there's a question
here
about
um yeah from dynbear
what do i think about the strange-shaped
asteroid that passed through the solar
system
and to cause speculation that was an
interstellar voyager
yeah that was this thing called umanuma
i guess which was what was it a year and
a half ago maybe
um it was a strange sort of cigar-shaped
thing and um the uh
the question and it was observed kind of
there are many asteroids millions of
asteroids
that orbit mostly between the orbits of
mars and
jupiter but they occasionally uh go
outside of that zone
and um occasionally they get close to
the earth and
uh um they go in other places but for
any asteroid
you can kind of track oh the asteroid is
orbiting around the sun and it's going
at a certain speed
and you can see oh there's an effect
from jupiter and it's pulling the
asteroid this way
and so on and so on and so on but this
particular asteroid
was weird because it was going at a
speed that was such that it was not
in orbit around the sun it was clearly
not going to orbit the sun it was
clearly something
which hadn't been orbiting the sun and
it wasn't going to orbit the sun it was
something that was just passing through
our solar system
coming from somewhere else and so that
that
was the first time something like that
had been observed the guess is that
actually quite a lot of these asteroids
or something like that
that come from other solar systems
um and uh for one reason or another they
were ejected from those solar systems
i don't know the rate at which asteroids
are being ejected from our solar system
it certainly will happen a typical way
it happens is the following
when when you have uh so so gravity
uh makes uh massive
bodies are attracted to each other the
attraction is proportional to one over
the square of the distance between the
bodies
so when the bodies are far apart that
means the
the force due to gravity is quite small
but when the bodies are close together
the force gets larger and larger and
when the bodies come really close
the force gets really quite large so for
example spacecraft
regularly that are visiting the outer
planets regularly use that
they do a kind of slingshot around
jupiter they go very close to jupiter
and they use the fact that there's a lot
of effect from gravity
as they swing around jupiter to make
them speed up
as they swing around jupiter and sort of
eject them out to the outer solar system
so that's a sort of a common way that
things can sort of gain
speed as a result of gravity they get
very close to some other
massive object and they don't quite hit
it they just go around it
and they're there that as they sort of
do that that partial orbit around it
they they um they're accelerating as
they go towards that object and that
acceleration
ends up causing them to have a high
speed that will cause them to sort of
eject out to somewhere else and so that
um
uh that process is one that potentially
can eject things from a solar system
and um other things like things crashing
into each other
and having fragments that get ejected
that's another process
and so on but so this particular thing
this umanuma thing
um the uh was probably ejected that way
from another solar system
um it was a bit weird looking it was a
kind of a long cigar-shaped thing it was
kind of a reddish color and it was sort
of a question
what if it was a spacecraft what if it
wasn't just
a rock what if it was uh uh
you know maybe it was you know it had
been traveling through
the um uh the galaxy for a billion years
and it was some kind of uh tourist
spacecraft from
another civilization how could you tell
and people were also saying
oh but it has some some emissions that
it's making some sort of gas that's
coming off it
of course it might have just had that
because it was being heated up by being
close to the sun
um but uh you know how could you tell
whether this was really
some sort of uh uh you know interstellar
spacecraft
or whether it was just a rock hard to
tell and it's particularly hard to tell
because
if we sort of imagine what would
that i mean imagine that you're showing
some archaeological remains
and it's like this is a pile of rocks
and but somebody says but actually it
was very carefully made
by this ancient civilization that had a
belief that when you make a pile of
rocks like this
it will cause it to rain or something
and that was a a
crucially very carefully and
purposefully made pile of rocks
but to us now it's like that's just a
pile of rocks
so it's very hard to tell when something
is sort of a
a whatever one means by intentionally
made versus
just a naturally created thing and so
there's a whole kind of chain of
philosophical issues
associated with that but you know if you
say was there sort of a human-like
civilization that made this
uh interstellar asteroid and
um and sort of sent it through our solar
system well probably not
and it's sort of the closer you say to
human-like
the closer you say it so just like
modern humans you know it so happens it
just was made by something like modern
humans
um that's something that becomes more
and more possible to to analyze so to
speak
let's see okay what maybe one last thing
um
the uh okay there's a comment from
frederick
about the uranium uranium uh
system um the uh
yeah it is worth saying that a critical
part of that
um uh cyber attack
i think was the actually actually
putting
a physical you know thumb drive into a
computer
it wasn't the case that that was you
know i was talking before about
about um uh the um
uh the fact that lots of devices are
connected to the internet
because why not i think this was a case
where that wasn't
the the way that that system was broken
into it it involved
physically putting you know something
into a computer there
and and you know this is one of the
things that happens um well
uh frederick is commenting on the
electrical grid
um and uh you know that's a complicated
thing because
uh it's not so popular these days but
when everybody was trying to figure out
how to how to wire up
the world that is you want to deliver
internet to people all over the place
how do you actually get those wires laid
that um
uh that give you the internet i have to
say it was kind of
kind of remarkable for me i i live in
not
in a somewhat rural area and um
at some point i i had a a very
high-end fancy you know internet
connection that i
i got and it was like okay you know
you know this internet connection is
going to arrive and then i see
sort of a road nearby these trucks and
the trucks are actually hanging this
piece of cable
and it's like okay there's my internet
and you know it's a physical piece of
cable that's being
um being uh um
uh being hung up and um yes in the end
you know cables have to be put somewhere
to actually
transmit the internet by the way with
with things like 5g
that's a wireless mechanism for getting
internet
to be sort of transmitted around and so
it's a little bit less of the story of
putting wires in the ground and maybe if
satellite
communications um become more widespread
although there's still some issues with
the speed of transmission to to and from
orbit and so on
but but in any case the the thing that
um
uh you know in the end you've got to
transmit the data somehow
through wires or through fiber optics or
whatever else you got to lay those fiber
optics somewhere
lay those wires somewhere and there was
for a period of time or
um 10 15 years ago maybe there was a big
sort of competition
of who has the right cables that have
been laid and so
for instance it's like well there's the
phone company it's got
a bunch of cables that have been laid to
set up people's phones
well there's the power company it's got
a bunch of cables that have been laid
to provide electric power for people oh
there's the water company
it's got a bunch of pipes that have been
laid that go to every house
um and so there was sort of a
competition about where should you put
the wires or the fibers that would
correspond to the internet and
and different um different groups uh
sort of brought up
different capabilities to reach things i
think one of the very common things
uh if you look at the very the backbone
of the internet it often goes along
train tracks
because it was possible to kind of buy
up the sort of the ability to
to put a piece of fiber along a train
track
um and they sort of go long distances
from here to there
so one of the things that was certainly
tried i don't know how popular it became
was um taking a power line and uh
usually it's just sending it you know
sending electric power at 60 hertz
frequency
but to put to also put in some
signal that would be i would not affect
you know just plugging a random
appliance into your power outlet
but would give you the ability to send
data
um along those lines i don't think that
that's been widely done i'm not sure
um there's a there's a quite separate
thing which is smart meters
which are is kind of a way of of uh when
you're
um uh and the smart grid and so on the
question of
of um uh what what exactly
you know you're you're in your house
you're using certain
electricity at certain times of day you
know what's the um
uh what's the best way to deliver
electricity
in the cheapest fashion to you one of
the things that's that's always sort of
interesting
when you switch something on in your
house you flick a light switch you turn
on you
you you know you make a washing machine
go something like this
um that any one of those things
will draw a certain amount of extra
power from your electrical system
and when the you know when the power
line comes into your house
there's just a little bit of extra
current that's being drawn when you
switch one of these things on
and there's also a little bit of a sort
of a sometimes when the switch is
switched there's a little bit of glit
a blip in the amount of current that's
drawn and so on
and so one of the things that's sort of
become a popular machine learning
application
is can you tell from those little little
blips
in the in the usage of power uh for some
house or business or whatever else
can you tell what devices are being
switched on and switched off and so on
and the answer is you can to some extent
and then given that
can you optimize certain kinds of things
about where you're getting power from
when and
and all those kinds of things and so
all of that kind of starts in meshing
kind of
the um uh the the kind of the um
electrical supply with things that are
more
internet related and and that involve
kind of
communication through the internet i
mean the other piece is the
smart grid for electricity of the
question of you've got these power
stations in different places
you've got solar power in different
places solar power is only generating
power when it's daylight
and you've got this thing and that thing
going on and the question is how do you
kind of match the power
how do you connect different parts of
the grid together
to um uh to optimize kind of the um the
way that power is delivered to different
places
and that's obviously in texas for
example recently
there was a big disaster with that um
it's been one of the kind of complicated
discussions that's gone on
is to what extent should the electric
power grid be completely connected
to what extent should it be something
where any place can
get power from sort of anywhere else i
remember when i was growing up in
england
in the 1960s and 1970s there was a lot
of pride that the british power grid
was somehow multiply redundant i don't
know if it was actually true it was said
at least
um and that you know even if you took
out some pieces it was there would still
be enough connectivity that you could
get
power to every place um and that's uh
sort of the
the good news about that is what i just
said the bad news is once everything is
connected
if something goes horribly wrong you can
have the whole system fail
um and that that happened for example in
new york 20 years ago or something
there was an issue of that kind um that
uh
was a result of having lots of
connectivity
and i think um uh but it's it's another
one of these sort of
uh interesting trade-offs um about how
these things work
well the um
uh okay should probably wrap up here
there was a comment here the wikipedia
article for uh
uma numero or however it's pronounced
i'm probably pronouncing it slightly
wrong
said that it exhibited non-gravitational
acceleration
well interesting i mean it's it's like
if it had rocket engines it could
exhibit
you know it could be sort of zooming off
in some direction and exhibit
acceleration that wasn't just due to the
force of gravity that could also happen
if for example um there was uh
a gas on its surface that got heated up
or something on its surface
let's say ice for example on its surface
and
uh the light of the sun heated up that
ice and caused it to turn into steam and
so you've got something where on one
side of the thing
it's uh that's facing the sun it's got
uh
essentially gas being produced that is
that is uh
uh you know streaming out from that side
of the object but there isn't gas
streaming out from the other side of the
object
so that will cause it to have some force
that pushes it in that case away from
the sun
so that's a mechanism by which you could
have uh
sort of non-gravitational acceleration
without having the fun
of having the sort of extraterrestrial
spacecraft
type story go on and then of course you
have to distinguish you say well
actually
it was uh you know the extraterrestrial
civilization had built it that way and
they painted
special stripes on it to to make it um
um
uh you know to make it work this way and
then they put camouflage
on it to make it so people wouldn't
think it had special stripes
put on it and so on and we're back now
to a question it was asked earlier about
occam's razor
the question is you know is that a
plausible explanation
or is the most likely explanation it's
just a rock from another solar system
or is the right explanation one that
says well there was this civilization
and it painted these things on and it
did this and did that and it camouflaged
as a rock
and so now it looks like a rock to us
but it really isn't and there's really
these other things
and that's kind of a typical you know
what are you going to believe occam's
razor
type question and you know it could be
the case that
that that theory of the extraterrestrial
civilization is the correct theory um
but it is our tendency to sort of think
the more the more likely scientific
answer is it's just a rock for another
solar system
but it's hard to know for sure all right
well uh thanks for um
for joining us here um we uh
uh i wish i'd been able to get to some
more of the interesting questions that
were asked
um i will uh look forward to continuing
next week and maybe
maybe we'll try and do a few more
questions with shorter answers um
next time i always i always find it
difficult to um
to answer in a short way because a
question
about one thing leads to some uh
something that i feel like oh people
will be interested to hear about this
about something else
and pretty soon we're on this kind of
random walk through
through lots of different topics but uh
it's always interesting for me i hope
you guys find it interesting
and i should wrap up here for now and
see you another